bon je vais pas vous faire attendre plus
longtemps si je suis venu vous voir
aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'ai quelque
chose à vous remettre
j'ai écrit ces quelques mots karim sur
l'envié méditer et poussé à continuer
depuis le début de rencontre est
je viens deuil familial j'ai perdu ma
mère
l'état d'esprit dans lequel je suis
actuellement les plus le même
j'ai besoin d'intimité de recul et venir
me marier dans deux semaines trop
compliqué
je suis vraiment désolé
alors voilà c'est cette fameuse lettre
qui a fait polémique sur les réseaux
pourquoi elle a fait polémique et ben on
s'est renseigné avec l'art délicat nous
on a fait appel à un graphologue a
priori l'écriture est celle d'une femme
donc ça veut dire que cette lettre n'a
pas été écrite par le prétendant mais
paris tient la production alors est ce
que ça change fondamentalement le sens
des mots je ne crois pas mais bon c'est
encore une carence bruit mais c'est
pouvant prévoir je suis pas d'accord moi
je trouve que pour le coup alors moi je
suis comme vous maintenant je suis je me
suis fait avoir j'aime ce programme est
là en voyant ça on se dit il ya
escroquerie
non mais je sais qu'ils vont nous sortir
oui inoue va écrire il a une mauvaise
écriture
il a demandé à sa soeur ou à sa voisine
mais là encore une fois quand on voit ça
on se dit
la production nous jouent un mauvais jeu
mais y ait vraiment un mari qu'on peut
ranger dans les télé réalités donc
forcément c'est scénarisé forcément il
ya une histoire racontée faut payer ce
genre de paramètres c'est pas un dock
c'est pas un magazine c'est de la télé
réunion qui jouerait sur accueil non non
non non pas du genre en deuil on dit
juste que la lettre c'est pas le gars
qu'il écrit plus tôt et ça on s'en fou
en soi qu'on puisse parler de
téléréalité à proprement boxé des gens
qui pensent - et pourquoi je pense que
c'était hier matin pur scandale
pourquoi je pense que cette émission est
un pur scandale ça parce que tout
simplement les protagonistes quand ils
viennent faire cette émission ils
pensent qu'ils vont trouver l'amour
alors que quand tu fais une télé réalité
tu sais ce qui t'attend et d'enseignants
n'a pas su arriver ce soir mais ce n'est
pas possible pour moi franchement d'un
mec vraiment pour moi c'est scandaleux
cette émission ne devrait pas exister
l'amour c'est pas des statistiques on
peut pas rigoler avec ça je suis désolé
j'étais alors c'est pour ça qu'ils
avaient alors si le milieu il ya le vrai
que je veux dire un truc il ya quelques
scat 1 souvent il ya des divorces ses
anciens sur quatre années moi je regarde
les mille que là vous savez quand même
qu'elle a dû faire le choix entre deux
candidats puisqu'il y avait deux
affinités donc été simple pour eux de
dire bon bah qu'il y avait une personne
qui se retirer en l'occurrence qu'elle
qui part avec l'autre personne qu'ils
étaient deux oui bon faire une espèce de
lettres qui écrit soit disant qu'il
serait écrit par une version wii wii
connaît en mariage ouais moi je trouve
d'une tristesse infinie cette émission a
effectivement ne devrait pas exister
c'est vraiment désacraliser le mariage
jean louis matte a requis dix ans
séparent les sénateurs parce qu'on ne
trouve pas ces désacraliser le mariage
d'abord moi je trouve c'est une
institution importante qu'il faut mais
on ne rigole pas du mariage non bah
ouais tu toi tu le sais alors qu'il
restait trois fois justement moi je
laisserais 4 x 4 fois mariage qui
inquiète mais le programme est ça me
choque pas peut-être comme tu disais
peut-être la personne avait une créature
ils disent ebay ou entre guillemets
d'année du temps qu'ils soient les ide à
l'image n'a personne à réécrire le
courrier sa sommet mais le conseil après
le concert toi je suis moins fan du
concept beaucoup c'est quand même un peu
dur tu ne te découvre alors le jour de
la mairie vous pensez que quand il ou
pas ce que c'est c'est hyper dur d'aller
annoncer à ses parents comme
correspondant aux 10 jouets d'accord
chaque fois quand on est dans la
séquence
c'est un peu difficile vous pensez que
les gens risquerait aller aussi loin
dans leur vie jusqu'à dire passer à la
télé casse alors combien avoir aussi
c'est le moment où ce qui se passe dans
la rencontre devant le maire et où on
dit à mon avis ils passeront pas l'hiver
ensemble ça va aller très très loin et
voit la tête de la mariée
on perd la vie adrien ne correspond pas
aux critères physiques de mon futur mari
donc je suis dans un moment d'hésitation
par les présentations avec plaisir
principaux plus loin confrontez vous à
prendre pour époux monsieur adrien
françois andré ici présents
[Musique]
et voilà c'est là qu'ils ont coupé le
programme
williams arthur la normale que c'est de
la télé à chaque sens critique on dit
que vous n'y a pas de choses innovantes
tout ça est bien là regard du suspense
on attend alors oui forcément moi je
vous cache pas que si mon fils me
demande de faire ça je meurs tout de
suite c'est pas possible est bonne et
moi en télé en tant que téléspectatrice
à de la nouveauté
il ya de l'émotion et du suspense et
d'émotion c'est du mariage improvisé en
33 secondes je suis désolé tu me mets
devant une émission télé réalité de
dating
j'aime parce que les candidats ils
apprennent à se découvrir on voit des
histoires ils sont ici crise hanger etc
mais là il n'y a aucune émotion ils se
connaissent pas se prennent au jeu
d'après lui c'est magali six rencontres
en deux minutes il s'en rappeler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le nez qui va voir il m'arrivait alors
c'est sûr c'est fini avec mes
qu'annabelle là je te jure bénard je te
jure avec pauline hazard est belle pour
l arrêter
ben voilà on va monter quelqu'un qui
aimerait se marier et dans un appel
daniel moreau vous du marivaux a écrit
une pièce qui s'appelle le jeu de
l'amour et du hasard
on voit que les paris vont presser un
caniveau dix mois de cité marine beau
nom mais c'est un peu c'est une loterie
j'aimerais marianne vous trouvez moi je
trouve ça plus sain que ces gens se
réunissent avec d après une étude
scientifique ils vont avoir des points
communs ils vont apprendre qu'elle est
une donnée à participer à l'émission
ah oui oui bah moi je trouve que c'est
c'est ma vie mais là ça prend des câbles
à la raison cette émission on voit
qu'ils sont un peu faibles ils sont
repris dans aucune émission de
candidature à lille alors qu'il n'est
pas on n'est pas au pmu là alors ça sert
tu comprends que dalle est ce que vous
êtes mariés non non je vous auriez fait
cette émission
non mais ça me fait penser ça va
peut-être venir comme à las vegas un
prochain épisode
il vient avec une chèvre et puis se
marier au premier regard qui tombe mal
voilà alors je q les rapports avec leurs
chèvres
oui
et oui mais ça c'est ça c'est d'autre
j'aime bien je garde c'est un jour vous
voyez des missions variées aux premières
animales c'est qu'on est là et qu'on a
franchi un gars mais si vous savez ce
qu'on peut construire le mariage c'est
beau le mariage est un mariage c'est la
pure très mariage c'est ses deux
mariages
voilà voilà mais moi je vous dis je
repars quand j'ai vu ça comme je te
pousse bon voilà un collector pas le
faire à chaque fois là pourquoi pas
avez-vous fait trop il ya une loi au pac
man tu as mangé toutes les vies banon
n'avait belge et il aime la fête ça il
fait beaucoup alors pas du tout ah bon
il aime la vie ce que ça donne
j'aime l'amour et j'aime l'amour c'est
comme les avants déposer quelqu'un faut
faire l'amour justement avec l avant
pour savoir si les peaux ça marche
une question des pauses ça ça dépend des
pots ah bon on va tâcher nommé et
rentrer entre julien et s'achèverait
vous n'est pas m'as bien barré